merci d'être avec nous ce matin avant de
parler de ce plfss ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui a
été examiné hier dans un climat assez
tendu avec la ministre on va en parler
un mot sur l'actualité ces
manifestations étudiantes hier pour
protester contre la précarité après
l'immolation d'un étudiant il y a
quelques jours les grilles du ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur on entame en
était enfoncé à paris est ce que vous
êtes inquiet de ce que oui et qui aimait
d'abord il faut condamner toute sorte de
violence c'est par abeille que un
dégradé un des grands devant des
bâtiments publics en s'attaquant au
ministère en question du matériel qu'on
doit faire avancer les choses mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui la situation de
nombreux étudiants et précaires et donc
il faut se pencher sur le dossier il
faut que la ministre n ce dossier à bras
le corps que puisse des réunions puisse
se tenir pour regarder faire des
propositions mais encore une fois c'est
pas avec la violence qu'on doit résoudre
ses problèmes
vous dites attention parce qu'on le voit
maintenant dans beaucoup de
manifestations les manifestations et
c'est un droit qui qu'il faut préserver
a le droit de pouvoir s'exprimer
manifester mais ces manifestations
doivent se faire un en bonne
intelligence et sans passer à des actes
qui seront condamnable et qui vont pas
dans qui m'ont pas rendre service à ceux
qui veulent porter un message à les
autres sujets hier c'est cette
interdiction des listes communautariste
emporté par bruno retailleau bruno
retailleau justement et xavier bertrand
qui était reçu par christophe castaner
l'auront une aisée nicole belloubet pour
parler de l'interdiction de ces listes
communautaire le patron des sénateurs
les républicains bruno retailleau était
au micro de fanny conquis à l'issue de
cette rencontre et il a mis en garde
contre eux le parti de l'impossible et s
bon l'écoutent
je ne vois pas en quoi les trois
principes que je rappelle de la laïcité
de la souveraineté nationale et de la
démocratie serait anticonstitutionnel
ils sont tirés précisément de la
constitution alors j'attends qu'on me
démontre linverse mais comme d'habitude
ceux qui veulent rien faire que ne rien
de bouge vont dire non c'est pas
possible
le parti de l'impossibilité sans doute
premier parti de france aujourd'hui
mais moi je pense que
on ne peut plus attendre il faut agir et
je pense comme xavier bertrand
d'ailleurs qui vaut mieux agir avant
plutôt que d'agir après michel ça va
vous reprendriez semoun bruno retailleau
le parti de l'impossibilité mais sans
doute le premier parti de france
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
phénomène qui quitteraient inquiétant 1
et kiki réel
donc on ne peut pas rester sans réagir
je pense que c'est un problème majeur
il faut il faut comme le dit bruno
retailleau prendre des dispositions et
prendre des ddd acte des actes qu'ils
soient forts on peut pas aujourd'hui
laissez les samis se se propager et et
investir des listes électorales se
présentait sur des listes électorales
c'est pas compatible avec la république
et avec la laïcité la démocratie
bien sûr il faut on peut pas on peut pas
chaque fois fermé les yeux
et puis un jour se réveiller en créant
ou non bono retailleau a tout à fait
raison de poser ce problème sur la table
il est réel on peut pas se cacher et
donc il faut que le ministre de
l'intérieur puisse lui prend des
dispositions nécessaires pour y faire
face
et vous pensez que c'est possible c'est
constitutionnel
il faut faire un constat on fait le
constat que ça existe maintenant il faut
qu'on travaille et que les services de
l'état avec et nous je pense que bruno
retailleau l'a dit nous sommes prêts à
travailler avec avec le gouvernement
pour trouver des solutions mais mais ce
n'est pas en mettant le problème sous là
sous le tapis combat combat avancé donc
si on fait le constat comme quoi c'est
réel et que c'est dangereux pour la
démocratie il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions bout de temps à retailleau a
des propositions à faire il faut que le
ministre de l'intérieur ne l'écoutent
allez on va passer cet examen du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale elle a débuté hier après-midi
dans l'hémicycle du sénat dont parle
avec notre journaliste parlementaire
quentin calmer
[Musique]
ça va un jour et l'examen de ce plfss a
donc commencé hier après midi et dès le
début une passe d'armes entre sénateurs
et gouvernement c'est ça début du
marathon budgétaire pour un mois au
sénat et déjà le ton qui monte en séance
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été renvoyé en
commission hier une manière pour les
sénateurs de signifier leur
mécontentement sur ce texte plusieurs
sources de mécontentement à vrai dire
dans le projet la défiance masque social
tel que présenté par le gouvernement
mais une en particulier et source
d'indignation sur les bancs de la droite
comme de la gauche
avant-hier dans le jdd la ministre de la
santé a donné des pistes pour la réforme
de l'hôpital public dans un contexte un
rôle c'est de forte mobilisation est des
personnels de l'hôpital et dans le jdd
donc elle donne des sources pour del
donne des pistes pour ce pour cette
réforme est donc ces annonces selon les
sénateurs cela va rendre caduque
le texte examiné en ce moment même dans
l'hémicycle du sénat écouter jean marie
le pen jean-marie vanlerenberghe
il est rapporteur général du budget à
quoi sert le parlement
à quoi sert
[Applaudissements]
à quoi sert ce le débat sur le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui est en cours dont nous
allons ouvrir la discussion aujourd'hui
au sénat si tout se passe en dehors de
cette enceinte
voilà à noter que le sénateur a été
applaudi sur les bancs de la droite
comme sur ceux de la gauche certains
sénateurs communistes ont même parlé
d'un budget insincère d'autres sur
twitter ont demandé dans quelle autre
démocratie le parlement et il traiter
ainsi cela devient une déplorable
attitude a tweeté le vice-président l
ère du sénat philippe dallier c'est donc
une question de respect du parlement
écoutez alain milon à ce sujet le
président la commission des affaires
sociales à trop vouloir se passer du
parlement et des corps intermédiaires
le gouvernement va se trouver bien seuls
face aux mouvements sociaux en cours ou
à venir
un face-à-face dangereux on risque des
mouvements de la rue qui peut conduire à
la paralysie et à l'abandon des réformes
mais peut-être pire encore
voilà je me cache pas sur le banc des
ministres on faisait grise mine pendant
ce temps là agnès buzyn a regretté le
fait que cette motion était déposée
écoutez là je comprends l'impatience et
la difficulté de discuter d'un texte
sans que l'ensemble des mesures andy
d'envisager n'ait pu être annoncé il en
va de la clarté de la sincérité des
débats qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur car plus que tout je respecte le
rôle du parlement garant de notre
démocratie sociale la commission des
affaires sociales a adopté une motion de
renvoi en commission il s'agit d'un acte
fort que nous avons entendu je crois
pourtant que l'hôpital mérite un débat
voilà la motion a été adoptée ensuite
dans la soirée la science est la science
été suspendus pendant plusieurs heures
une majorité a même refusé de reprendre
les débats dans l'hémicycle pendant
plusieurs heures donc un début de séance
qui donne le ton et la mesure du
mécontentement des sénateurs au premier
jour de l'examen du projet de loi de
finances pour la sécurité sociale
merci beaucoup quentin pour ce compte
rendu de séance michel savin on l'a vu
en séance compliquée et mouvementée en
ce début d'examen de texte est ce que
vous pensez qu agnès buzyn vous a
entendu qu'elle a entendu votre colère
et votre mécontentement mais ce n'est
pas la première fois que le gouvernement
à cette attitude vis-à-vis du parlement
et c'est ce qui est inquiétant et quoi
pour voir mépris du parlement
je pense que c'est surtout le fait que
le gouvernement ne veut pas engager les
débats avec le parlement ne veut pas
entendre le parlement et c'est le rôle
du parlement de débattre sur le budget
et un ami on a tout à fait raison
comment peut-on débat d'un budget qui va
être votée le 19
novembre et des annonces qui vont être
faites par la ministre le vin dont on
connaît pas les retards des financières
et 6 passes calendrier elle a dit hier
les allées en fait après le vote du
budget bon comment peut-on rester
crédible vis-à-vis de ce comportement
comment quel rôle joue le parlement dans
ce dense dans cette discussion en
sachant que pertinemment les annonces
qui vont être faites par les ministres
auront un impact fort sur le budget mais
je vous donne un autre exemple un sur
sur le respect du parlement s'était pas
passé à lhassa cela s'est passé à
l'assemblée nationale li a eu quelques
jours sur le vote du budget sur un
domaine que je suis particulièrement sur
le sport des députés de toutes
sensibilité qu'on votait un amendement
pour relever la taxe buffet de 15
millions que ça a été voté voter au sein
de l'assemblée nationale
trois heures après le ministre du budget
rose est voté cet amendement et demandé
sa majorité de voter compte ça a été le
cas donc le cieux cet amendement a été
rejeté trois heures après quel respect
par rapport au parlement par rapport à
des députés qui avaient débattu qui
avaient présenté leur projet qui avaient
voté qui avait obtenu gagnent cause
trois heures après deux ministres
attendus que y est beaucoup moins de
parlementaires d'un au sein de
l'hémicycle pouf revenir sur ses
décisions
si elle ne pas respecter le parlement
les députés et des sénateurs
alors du coup hier soir les travaux ont
quand même repris après de longues
discussions
l'examen s'est poursuivie et ce
notamment sur la question de la
compensation des mesures gilet jaune à
la sécurité sociale puisque dans le
projet de loi de financement initiale
l'état ne compensait pas à ces mesures
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
l'abaissement du taux de csg pour une
partie des retraités
hélas le sénat est bien forcément à
voter linverse du gouvernement disant
que l'état devait compenser ces mesures
à la sécurité sociale mais du coup qui
les financent ces murs et la dette le
déficit
encore une fois le gouvernement avait
annoncé
à l'époque de ces annonces qui prendrait
sur des réductions de dépenses
c'est au fil du temps c'est devenu une
augmentation de la dette nous sont cons
demande c'est que c'est bien le
gouvernement qui a pris ses dispositions
c'est bien le gouvernement qui a annoncé
ces nouvelles mesures qui étaient suite
aux manifestations des gilet jaune et
suite aux discussions qui a eu entre les
différents partenaires
aujourd'hui vu que ces décisions sont
liés à des mesures nouvelles prises par
l'état c'est d'état qui doit prendre en
charge et non le budget la sécu qui
vient encore une fois être en déficit et
on reporte encore les déficits qui sont
importants ce qui est quand même très
dangereux demain sur le même la
pérennité de notre système donc il faut
qu'on sait que l'actuel les maisons va
vous entendre qu'une fois que le texte
sera de retour à l'alerté de lui dire
c'est pas possible de continuer dans
cette dans ce système on peut pas
continuer l'état à faire des grandes
annonces et des capacités de pouvoir
trouver des financements pour payer les
annonces qui ce qu'on est et qui ont été
faites c'est une question de
responsabilité
on est dans des collectivités on a
l'obligation d'équilibrer nos budgets
aussi bien les communes les départements
les régions et l'état ne nous donne pas
une bonne image et ne donnons pas un
exemple à suivre ni au reste les
collectivités de faire des annonces et
d'incapacité pouvoir les financer c'est
un vrai problème
alors on parlait de cette crise des
hôpitaux puisque le problème c'est que
ce projet de la financement de la
sécurité sociale se tient en pleine
crise des hôpitaux vous l'avez dit agnès
buzyn doit faire des annonces qu'est ce
que vous attendez vous comme annonce
pour régler cette crise alors qu'il ya
une grande manifestation demain je pense
que les les les attentes sont nombreuses
on voit bien qu'ils auront on a des
vrais problèmes sur la qualité des
services notamment en termes de moyens
on voit que les services sont
complètement saturé
nous avons dans notre région rencontrer
les professionnels qui nous ont alertés
sur le problème des urgences qui sont en
situation de rupture
la problème de la formation les
problèmes de la revalorisation aussi des
salaires de certains métiers
donc on voit bien que c'est un tout qui
doit être travis c'est un enjeu majeur
aussi pour l'ensemble d'un autre de nos
concitoyens parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
le reconnaître le système français et
est un des meilleurs au monde
il faut il faut le préserver le
conserver de l'améliorer mais surtout
donner les moyens à ceux qui aujourd'hui
amène ses soins qui prennent qui
travaillent qui font un travail
fantastique d'un des conditions des fois
parfois difficile leur donner les moyens
de le faire de très bonnes conditions
il ya des problèmes d'organisation aussi
du temps de travail donc tout ça doit
être je pense que les les partenaires
ont tous est jugé sur la table on attend
les propositions qui vont être faites
par la ministre et j'espère qu'il
répondra au moins partiellement à la
temps de ses personnels allez le sénat
qui est aussi souhaité mettre la réforme
des retraites au coeur de ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale avant que nous entendre sur ce
sujet on va te rendre dans une rédaction
locale c'est le principe de cette
émission aujourd'hui direction tour
retrouvez nos partenaires de la nouvelle
république bonjour monsieur le gall
merci d'être avec nous journalistes à la
nouvelle république on va parler des
retraites puisque jean paul delevoye est
en plein tour de france 1 après metz
amiens peau le haut commissaire à la
réforme des retraites sera à poitiers
chez vous ce sera le 21 novembre pour un
exercice de pédagogie sur cette réforme
des retraites et mathieu il répondra aux
questions des lecteurs de la nouvelle
république
et de centre-presse est ce que vous
annoncer aujourd'hui dans vos éditions
marianne jean paul delevoye ancien
ministre ancien sénateur du
pas-de-calais a repris son bâton de
pèlerin on le sait le haut commissaire a
travaillé pendant plusieurs mois sur le
futur système universel de retraite
on en connaît désormais les contours et
c'est un changement majeur qui est
proposé aux français
d'où la nécessité d'aller répondre aux
nombreuses interrogations aux
inquiétudes sur le terrain et les
questions des français sont déjà très
nombreuses avec cette réforme
chacun veut savoir s'il sera perdant ou
gagnant et cette rencontre avec les
poitevins elle a d'autant plus
d'importance et un compte c'est le
climat social et
tendu oui le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que le chemin du pèlerin delevoye
est semé d'embûches d'abord ses
rencontres avec les français nous ramène
aux tentatives de l'exécutif d'endiguer
la crise des gilet jaune il y un an
emmanuel macron s'était lui aussi
déplacé sur le terrain dans l'espoir de
renouer le dialogue avec une franche du
pays qui se sent mise à l'écart
ensuite il y à la journée de
mobilisation du 5 décembre contre la
réforme des retraites
et cette journée c'est un véritable test
pour l'exécutif or on sait déjà que le
front syndical s'est élargi la cgt
cheminots premier syndicat de la sncf a
rejoint l'unsa ferroviaire sud rail et
force ouvrière et en plus de tout ça et
bien il ya une certaine cacophonie une
dissonance entre jean paul delevoye et
le gouvernement sur l'entrée en vigueur
de cette réforme
oui c'est cette fameuse clause du grand
père confronté à la pression de la rue
le gouvernement pourrait-il l'activer
pour reculer l'entrée en vigueur de la
réforme
jean paul delevoye avait exprimé un peu
vite sans opposition à cette clause qui
ajouterait un 43e système de retraite
aux 42 qui existe déjà un coup de fil
d'edouard philippe plus tard et l'état
parle d'une seule voix le débat est
ouvert et rien n'est tranché
alors concrètement mathieu le gall
message pour vos lecteurs les lecteurs
de la nouvelle république et de
centre-presse comment on fait pour poser
ces questions à jean paul delevoye y
participer à ce débat le 21e longue
oui vous avez raison rien revenons à
l'essentiel la nouvelle république et
centre presse proposent à leurs lecteurs
de rencontrer le haut-commissaire
retraite le 21 novembre à poitiers
au programme des ateliers thématiques et
un échange direct avec jean paul
delevoye
alors quel que soit votre âge votre
statut que vous ayez un emploi ou non
que vous soyez retraités ou non
rendez vous sur les sites internet de la
nouvelle république et centre presse
pour vous inscrire et si vous ne pouvez
pas vous déplacer
jean paul delevoye répondre à quelques
questions posées par les internautes
et bien c'est noté merci beaucoup mais
c'est le gagne on suivra tout ça le 21
novembre on va voir vos de une en selle
de centre presse
autoliv la cfdt veut elle limiter la
casse le syndicat qui veut réduire
l'impact du plan social annoncé et qui
pourrait se traduire par la suppression
de 110 emplois
et puis à la une de la nouvelle
république eh bien ce sont ces cette
triste anniversaire des attentats du 13
novembre les victimes attendent le
procès du 13 novembre merci beaucoup m
le gars d'avoir été en direct avec nous
depuis tour on va revenir à ce sujet
cette réforme des retraites michel savin
est-ce que vous pensez que la pédagogie
ce tour de france qui essaye de faire
jean paul delevoye bien ça sera
suffisant pour faire accepter cette
réforme
je ne sais pas si ce sera suffisant mais
c'est nécessaire de le faire il faut
surtout que le gouvernement ait une
ligne et qu'elle se tienne à cette ligne
parce qu'on voit bien et le reportage le
démenti un peu de la cacophonie
il ya des annonces qui sont faites il
revient sur ces annonces
on sent que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
veut faire un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière c'est notre système qui
aujourd'hui est en péril donc on voit
bien que les dépenses sont en
augmentation les recettes sont à la
baisse c'est l'effet du baby boom donc
il faut être
on est tous conscients que ce système ne
peut pas continuer s'il n'y a pas de
grande réforme
voilà notre groupe fait des propositions
notamment sur le lot le porter l'âge de
la retraite à 64 ans est ce qui a été
introduit par votre groupe par la
commission des affaires sociales
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
à 64 à l'horizon de 2025 donc chez vous
et ben oui tout ça 100 euros c'est la
seule solution c'est pas si c'est pas la
seule solution il faut travailler sur
les régimes spéciaux il faut pas
reporter ce problème est infiniment donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien
de départ il faut booster la journée
s'est regardé ce qui se passait il ya 20
ou 30 ans les gens de commencer à
travailler à 18 ans 19 ans 20 ans est
ravie jusqu'à plus de 60 ans aujourd'hui
c'est un constat le après la prise de
travail se fait beaucoup plus tard 25 28
25 26 27 28 ans avec les études et aux
donc la cote des temps la cotisation est
beaucoup plus court donc il faut
allonger ce temps de travail pour
permettre pour encore une fois sauvé ce
système de retraite qui est encore une
voix a quand même fait aussi partie de
l'adn de notre république et qui
aujourd'hui est quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'on défendre à bout de bras pour aller
jusqu'au bout sur la réforme met en
place il faut qu'il aille jusqu'au bout
il peut pas faire marche arrière encore
une fois l'enjeu est très important et
là on peut pas jouer petit bras sur ce
sur ce dossier on va parler d'un autre
sujet c'est le sport puisque vous
apporter des amendements dans ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale sur la question du sport
notamment pour faciliter la pratique
faciliter l'accès au sport et il est
question de ne plus rendre le certificat
médical obligatoire oui ces deux mais
pour tout le monde pour tous les partis
sans bien sûr les jeunes mais aussi les
adultes
alors on fait une exception pour les
fédérations et des compétitions qui sont
à risque et la sai on laisse la main aux
fédérations pour bien cibler quels sont
les compétitions les sports qui sont à
risque et qui nécessitent eu une
certificat médical donc et pour les
autres c'est sur la pressé c'est la
personne qu'il ferait une déclaration
pour déclarer ses ailes et béate à
pratiquer le sport
aujourd'hui il faut assouplir les choses
je pense que toutes les fédérations sont
sont partantes sur cette proposition
on va la soumettre on verra quelle en
sera l'issue au niveau du débat mais
j'ai des doutes sur ce que la fal au
gouvernement vous avez des garanties si
j'ai pas de garanties mais bon sens
voudrait que cet amendement soit votée
parce qu'il va dans le sens de
l'évolution de la pratique du sport
d'inciter les gens à mieux pratiquer le
sport
encore une fois il est pas il est pas
pour toutes les compétitions parce que
bien sûr qu'ils aient des sports qui
sont à risque est sûre cela il faut
qu'il y ait une garantie d'avoir que le
pratiquant et la possibilité la garantie
de poids le pratiquer dans de bonnes
conditions est ce que pour élargir la
pratique de l'activité physique selon
vous il faudrait une activité physique
sur ordonnance oui on l'a on avait
proposé le d'expérimenter à l'échelle
d'une région cette mesure parce que
chaque fois qu'on essaie de avancer
cette solution on nous met en avant le
coût que ça peut représenter au niveau
de la sécurité sociale il est indéniable
qu'il ira à coup sûr la première année
d'abord il faut qu'on puisse mesurer sur
trois ou quatre ans les effets qu'aurait
ce dispositif aussi bien sur les points
économiques mais surtout sur le plan de
la santé et tous les mettrait les coûts
des maladies qu'ils sont engendrées par
la non pratique de l'activité physique
ça engendre et voilà une économie sur
s'ensabler une deuxième économie c'est
que les patients qui doivent su qu'ils
ont qui doivent subir des traitements
si les blés les praticiens les médecins
leur demande plutôt de pratiquer
l'activité physique et sportive au lieu
de prendre des médicaments c'est aussi
une économie au niveau de la sécurité
sur le remboursement des médicaments
donc on propose une expérimentation
l'échelle d'une région pour mesurer les
bienfaits aussi bien en termes
d'économie qu'en termes de santé sur ce
dispositif
et puis si on s'aperçoit que c'est un
dispositif qui est positif de l'étendre
à l'ensemble du pays allez on va passer
à votre revue de presse 1 monsieur le
sénateur et vous allez voir qu'il est
aussi question de sport on va voir ça
avec entend calmer car elle et quand on
commence avec presse océan alors c'est
pas dans l'isère mais il est question
sport tout à fait ça va prolonger le
débat que vous étiez en train d'avoir en
ce moment sur le plateau sur la question
du certificat médical afin de son
obligation
c'est effectivement la question d'un
trait concernante qui fait la une de
presse océan car il ya le débat dans
l'hémicycle mais il ya le débat aussi
pour les parents d'élèves qui s
interrogent entre l'opportunité d'avoir
comme cela une forme de surveillance de
la santé de leurs enfants et d'autres
qui trouvent que et bien effectivement
ce trafic ce certificat médical et
contraignant donc on voit ce débat dans
presse océan press océan qui revient
aussi sur les aspects plus sénatoriaux
législatif avec l explication de ce que
voudrait faire la commission des
affaires sociales dans le journal allez
on va revenir en isère avec le dauphiné
libéré
voilà le dauphiné libéré qui revient sur
une information qui date du mois de
septembre de la fin septembre et l'
incendie de la mairie on a appris hier
que cet incendie avait été revendiquée
vous le voyez hein ça fait la une du
dauphiné libéré dans son édition de
grenoble une revendication prise au
sérieux d'un site libertaire et qui a
revendiqué cet incendie prise au sérieux
par le procureur de la république
un incendie de l'hôtel de ville le 30
septembre qui fait suite à une autre
série 1 2 1 sans dire on voit plusieurs
photos est effectivement tout une toute
une série de bâtiments qui ont qui ont
été incendiées comme ça depuis depuis
2010 est que ce soit les locaux de
france bleu isère ou encore l'église
saint jacques en janvier dernier ou
encore
et bâtiments de l'entreprise eiffage ou
celui d'un centre de culture
scientifique toute une série d'incendiés
comme ça qui inquiète effectivement en
isère et quand on va terminer avec place
grenette point fr l'inauguration d'un
institut de formation des personnels de
santé steyer voilà on nous dit que cet
institut était attendue de longue date
10 mille mètres carrés d'un nouveau
bâtiment pour accueillir effectivement
un institut de formation commun au chu
et à lester de grenoble donc on le voit
cette inauguration très attendu a eu
lieu hier comme on le voit sur cette
photo
merci beaucoup quand on a une réaction
du sénateur à cette revue de presse
peut-être sur cet incendie de l'amérique
grenoble qu'on a appris oui oui c'est
incendie qui fait suite comme vous
l'avez rappelé de plusieurs autres actes
de malveillance ou qui ont ce qu'ils ont
et qui ont ciblé des et des équipements
très variés
une radio france bleue des équipements
culturels d'une église une école on peut
que dénoncer ces actes qui sont qui
attaquent la démocratie et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit intraitable sur en
terme de sanction sur ceux qui
commettent ces actes parce que encore
une fois on ne peut pas aller c'est d'un
autre pays
des personnes s'attaquent est encore une
fois à des bâtiments qui servent la
démocratie qui servent le bien commun
lorsqu'on s'attaque à une école à un
lieu culturel n radio mais c'est la
liberté de la presse et le fait de
pouvoir dans les lieux culturels et les
écoles nos enfants ils y participent
c'est la vie de la société
c'est donc il faut que vraiment que
j'espère que rapidement les auteurs
seront seront connus et qui seront
lourdement sanctionnés amant puisque sur
ce qui s'est passé dans votre région
dans dix ans ce tremblement terre qui a
touché la drôme et l'ardèche à proximité
de centrales celles du tricastin celle
de classe dans l'ardèche est-ce qu'il
faut s'inquiéter sur la sécurité de ses
centrales nucléaires
je pense qu'il faut surtout être très
vigilant et que toutes les mesures ont
été prises pour vérifier si ce séisme a
eu une incidence sur les bâtiments de
cette centrale et on sait que cette
centrale ces équipements sont situés
dans un sur dix des territoires qui sont
qui sont répertoriés pour être des
territoires qui peut avoir des séismes
donc je pense qu'il est d'abord la
construction a été faite en prenant en
compte ce phénomène mais il faut être
vigilant et je pense que l'arrêt qui a
été déclenché dans rapidement a créé va
permettre à tous les techniciens de
vérifier l'état des bâtiments et bien
merci beaucoup merci mais ça